I'm just kidding
it's me pastiche what's up guys um I'm
gonna be doing a Minecraft Survival
Series and with a little twist now you
see I mean look like hair brown with my
glowing eyes but my arms are not up and
I got some extra stuff that's just my
skin and this series will have hair
runnin I've harab harab brine mod on
alone shouldn't change this render
distance I got a Harold Brown mod on so
he shall be appearing to plague us with
His infinite and oh by the way the mod
just makes him more no and so I'll see
him probably about every half an hour
normally there's a lot more rare than
that alright so I made myself little
Ness house and it's nice and cozy I
slept in the bed so spawn there and then
I got some goods now first thing yeah
and I got my awesome white lip hat Oh
sexy sexy time now first thing we're
gonna do
I saw a dungeon right there right before
I started recording so we are gonna we
are going to equip ourselves with some
torches I don't I have no sticks let's
take a tree down tree I come for your
babies we need some torches if we're
gonna to be disabling that dungeon
whenever the dungeon is could it be a
skeleton or zombie or
oh yeah seven skeleton or zombie or
spider
it's about it or could be a pig let's
get ass pig spawner of sheep get off
hair bad sheep actually I was thinking
about adding another plugin to make the
Sheep all crazy actually all animals
crazy cuz I was playing on a server and
it's pretty awesome when the sheep and
the pigs hate you back when you attack
them for you so I flew when I spawned in
the world I flew around to find the best
location and I chose this location
because it got some awesome stuff I mean
we got a
we got an awesome Hill extreme Hills
bottom that we're in and over yonder
wait I'm gonna get is a perfect view
from the house one sec uh tomb I need
dirt dirt I just heard a spider as well
and you go here and at from our house
right here as a perfect you view through
that hole get a little more render
distance wait for it wait for it yes
it's true really straight through there
we got a I'm actually gonna blow all
that up so we can see through it because
the Sun the Sun Goes Down there it's
beautiful but over there we got a swamp
biome and a snow biome and to our right
we have a desert biome so friends we got
everything is about forest so yeah
always that mmm so yes now in this
specific mod they're going to be adding
in I gotta always be on the lookout for
heroin Hera Brian how do you say I never
know how to say it so someone tell me
how to say like make the eye or the ear
bring her brine Oh heart she's an enemy
just inanimate did he give iron ore all
he's is he pissed off I think you pissed
off
no no just go away be gone be gone all
that noise is so loud you really need a
nice sound is low sound of that 11
percent alright well let's get our let's
get up to that dungeon so yeah basically
the only thing we do not have is a force
but whatever and in this specific hair
burn mod hair Brian oh my gosh I'm gonna
be plugging that the entire time we have
awesome quick spider dungeon and
they are working it's not completed yet
oh they're still working on they're
gonna add another dimension to have yeah
it's definitely a spider one they're
getting another dimension to the right
they're gonna add another dimension
where hair runs from and a bunch of
other stuff right now they do have some
stuff blocks to heat her burn away from
your chest cuz he can steal from your
chest man he's a dirty round thief I'll
smite three nice
we got some good goods anything in here
I'll cast from redstone some we can
bucket buckets nice I'm gonna take these
chests and I'm gonna leave this just in
case I want to I want to make a spawning
thing later but I will take this mossy
cobblestone because this is mossy
cobblestone Lee looks sexy and yeah this
one there will be adding that stuff so I
look I really look forward to when they
get that in and I would be covering this
right now they have this thing called a
Harrow brain Harrow bane and it you can
build it it's costly cost a diamond
blocks and and some other stuff in a
blaze rod and it tells you if a hair
brownies with a within like a hundred
ish blocks of you it tells you how many
blocks he is from you and also you can
switch it to attack mode to attack her
button but be warned her burn can never
be killed only repelled for time but
when he gets repels he drops XP exp so
it's pretty freakin nice I'm just
getting all this all this good old
Moscow coal take that get that XP see I
did a little stuff to make my house it
was about rank level ranks minecraft
Franks
it's about level if I go up how'd you
spawn what the how that could he spawn
it's a light putting a torch there
looking modders I'm gonna torch this all
up
there shouldn't have any more spawning
troubles with these dastardly spiders
but I can belong at my dry Franks
Peregrin something like that and you can
turn into attack mode I said that a long
time ago I completely lost my train of
thought
screw you spider screw you and your
family I will eventually destroy all
your generations of your kind from the
spawner so haha I love the last laugh I
heard noise I think it's becoming night
time we gotta gotta go sleepy time go
sleep and sleep in a nice warm bed I
think I got all the mossy kelp stone
plus I'm called 52mm
that's sexy also we have a ton of cows
Oh cow farm will not be a problem
problemo shall not be about blame Oh
actually I'm gonna hit some of these yes
some seeds so you want to start a wheat
farm to grow us some breads you know we
got some wheat from the dungeon furnace
wheats wheats make your picking strong
actually milk does that and I have a
bucket haha now give your milk I have
shown the milk I just heard some water
below me this is a ravine this is not a
ravine I'm getting a little bit of lag
so yeah this mod it's not as apparent
like I know there are other hair bran
mods where you can actually summon him
via stuff but this one you cannot it's
kind of a two-way thing wow wow wow wow
run away no where is it run oh my god
there's nothing there oh my no no just
run oh my gosh freakin invisible spiders
did not think that's part is mod still
don't think it is
spiders just hacking for hackers hate
hackers didn't know didn't know hackers
were minecraft I guess so I'm gonna put
one here and lay down my chest get
double chest going and all its sexy
glory put something cool in here when I
want to cook some stuff up and really
just throw everything in there and then
take out what I want
mmm I can make a bow take a bow also
alright
nope there's some lava oh there's also
some Ingrid above ground lava near me so
that's a cool that's a cool tang some
pine wood so I also know I want that I
just want to make some some a fishing
rod fish ain't bad for some foods from
nom nom screw much mom's well if I'm
gonna have a bow I probably want the
arrows on me as well this is for if I
get poisoned and yeah it's let's go
sleep it down oh okay freakin ah
sorry peoples if you are if you I
wouldn't be surprised if you heard that
but because I was loud because I'm not
using my big Yeti microphone but I am
using a I'm using a good microphone just
that that was extremely loud I set a
timer for myself so I know when to end
the video about ten minutes like I can
still go a little bit longer than seven
minutes would be a kind of short video
but that was loud that scared me felt
like someone was calling me scare me
don't you scare me phone
hahaha pin as long as we get once apon
from each tree would be okay I kind of
want more than one per tree I guess
that's all I'm getting from that show
you one perjury for you there
actually about me haha I still feel
Bonilla tree grow tree grow
yes neither of them are mother trees ha
ha it looks so nice all creeper
grape I'm about to super snipe you so
good soup snipe ha OH
he's chasing me did die on impact
tango Down tango Down no fork East alive
wait oh I do not want him to blow up my
house no no no don't block them both of
hawk tango Down
tango dancing oh well that wasn't the
timer than the video so I should
probably do that this has been a little
bit month at so I hope you people enjoy
it is sad we did not get to see a Harrow
bran Harold Britain someone please tell
me how to say that I don't know how to
say that the life of me we do yeah we
didn't see him but he is supposed to
show up every 30 minutes so maybe next
episode this is awesome that we got to
start off with a dungeon I mean it's
beautiful pearl it's beautiful so I'll
show you my face the HERA brown face and
by the way this skin is the hair bird
hunter so I shall slay in here burn the
dare come near me just make sure hair
opening behind me like on top one of
these mountains you scare the crap out
of me I think we're OK Hey oh that that
is a zombie repeat that is a zombie for
those harab run all these zombies make
me think it's Herbert okay I'm leaving
on stars I'm getting scared
oh my gosh okay I hope you enjoyed my
name is the prestige the perceived
actually it's just perceive all my
freaking was that
oh my gosh oh yes I'm I'm freaking
scared as crap
so almost leap I'm asleep I'm asleep and
peace out guys hope you enjoyed the
video